[Musik]
na ja kaum kommt die sonne raus so
siehts geraten aus ihren löchern wie
meinen saison 13 auch die schöne wetter
raus in ihren garten ihr seid aber
natürlicher brandl ist es nicht ganz
herrlich diese frische brise und wie die
natur den frühling art mit richten sie
das auch jedem überhaupt nichts mehr der
blues roots
dies ist wie man dies ist der tisch ist
ja auch ein ich bin auf den auch man
allergisch die koreaner auf meinen
japanischen fächer aber das kann
überhaupt nicht sein ergänzt so
wunderbar harmonisch meinen zähnen
garten und er soll hier wachsen und
gedeihen wachsen und gedeihen 5 cm tbh
hinaus also höher installiert
ach so geht es ja nicht wie ich sehe
ihre brantl sind in der 10 philosophie
nicht wirklich bewanderte ein baum im
garten symbolisiert leben mensch sein
der im grunde genommen sogar das eigene
ich doch viel mehr eigentlich brach über
kühe symbol bei - selber dürfen jetzt
aber sieht man vielleicht könnten sie
das ja am boden seien immer mit nach
hause nehmen am abend dann müssen wir
den schlafzimmer symbolisierten ihr
eigenes irgendwie mochte konnte versteht
es jetzt zwar nicht ganz so herbram sich
machen einen vorschlag wollen wenn ich
unsere kleine unstimmigkeit besprechen
vielleicht bei einem glas tee fernglas
was
ich habe einen wundervollen grünen tee
der wird bei vollmond aufzeichnung hand
gepflückt ja und wenn die grünen strom
hätte man kann auch wenn noch immer
umstritten
aber gerade bei voll ja ist schon recht
wurde sowieso konnte aber ich hätte doch
eine wunderbare hopfenkaltschale
übersieht auch ich haben sie mehr hier
wenn es vielleicht das ohne barrieren
auch eventuell nein danke wirklich nicht
wir am helllichten nachmittag zeigt gott
vor häufig gmbh wie man es mit da sagt
die makrobiotische ernährung aber etwas
ganz anderes datum rostiger marco
idiotische ernährung also jetzt ein
vampir oder nicht nein wirklich alkohol
bekommt mir nicht
das war aber bei mir genauso alt wie es
mir auch nicht bekommen
aber übung macht den meister geht es
richtig ständiges training das ist doch
ganz wichtig jetzt hat es immer hier
dort die kameraden die um auch zu wenig
trainiert werden daraus macht
deutschlands schnecken in der birne
quitte geht das heute gibt die sagen wir
es offen gibt es einen schöneren trug
diesen tierchen das zen lehrt dass alle
lebewesen gleich sind ja da hat er recht
rcb hoben idee schnecken auch sehr viel
gemeinsam zum beispiel die liebe zu mir
gesagt herr brand ich würde mich jetzt
doch wieder gerne dem schmücken meines
gartens widmen ist ja viel arbeit nicht
haben sind wahnsinnig froh aber das war
jetzt darf nur so schmücken freilich
[Musik]
fertig hallo hallo wichtig dass dieses
mal auf mir noch 2 sekunden schon haben
sie nicht ernst ist weg aber die klänge
dieses windspiel harmonisieren doch die
energie von körper und seele
lauschen sie nochmal das geräusch des
haben und sich ungefähr so viel luft
schutt serie
jetzt glänzt ist weg das ist ja
ruhestörung aber ihre regelmäßigen
saufgelage sind wohl keine ruhestörung
was das ist keine störung bei dies ist
nämlich bayerische lebensart japanischer
fans schuldig machen dort feng shui
kommt aus china
die chinesen seien japaner jetzt wollen
sie mir aber wohl nicht weismachen dass
es auch in bayerische sitte ist dass sie
ihre saufkumpane nacht für nacht an
meinem garten fahren erleichtern nach
dem stimmt das geht nicht das ist ja
nazis das wären wir sofort abstellen in
zukunft werden nämlich direkt in einem
fernschreiben grunzen
das werden sie nicht wagen ich habe
dieses szenario mehrfach beobachtet und
auch fotografisch festgehalten
grafisch festgehalten das szenario sieht
das wissen dass sie nicht mehr in den
freunden in blogs pioniere oder was ja
wie klar die seine pervers genau pervers
seien sie dies bedauern
anfänglich waren wurden stehen ich bitte
sie das ist eine künstlerisch
hochwertiges kultur nach dem bekannten
motiv die liebe ja die feng shui lehre
besagt dass diese statue den
lebensbereich partnerschaft positiv
aktivieren kann partnerschaft positiv
aktive yoga partnerschaft ja irgendwo
auch das wäre mir doch jetzt sony weisen
wohin er das nur für ein spiel kunden
gerne erschien die frau jetzt bloß weil
sie deutschland tom watson im garten
stehen nein natürlich nicht so direkt
aber in übertragenem sinne kann es sein
dass die partnerschaftliche
entwicklungen eben positiv beeinflusst
wird
nur queen die suisse ich bin jetzt darf
der bringt daher schwimmen hin und her
ein schuldiger für mich genauso zu
stehen ich bin fingern oder sich die
reise nach experimenten
so darf ich vorstellen ist der herr feng
shui und sowieso richtig verstanden habe
dann kommen jetzt kein ort der spitzen
zorn vorbei und der der wert rolllade
schaffen hier unternimmt nicht ist
letztlich wie sie das immer versuchen
eins zu eins zu übersetzen so geht das
natürlich überhaupt nicht da hat ja auch
hier kann man noch etwas damit zu tun
ich meine das kann jahre dauern in jedem
fall vielleicht sogar jahrzehnte
gewandelt
was sie sich schon lange mal fragen
wollte wo haben sie denn diese
herzergreifenden gartenzwerge er hätten
sie nicht den kaffee trinken zu gehen
oder den grünen tee grüner tee also mit
liebe caliente muss allerdings noch
keine mir wieso aus er muss bei vollmond
musste wog in mir jetzt genau hier
vielleicht nach hause diese gute idee
britische langspecht scheiden
[Applaus]